on the opposite end
he has them open
throws one up in the air Smith caught it
for the wing hole
and improbable Southern League opening
victory for the Houston Rockets
wow
what a pass
Victor wendbanyama is the main course
tonight but
Jabari Smith just one Upton before the
big man could take the floor
you
33 points for Jabari Smith
he had four points at half and tari
Eason found him in the nick of time
[Applause]
oh why are you getting in front of them
force him to catch the ball going away
from the basket
[Applause]
wow Portland could have run out the
clock went for the LOB
no reason to get on that side of Jabari
Smith
what you need to do is force him to go
away from the basket you just stay
between the ball in the basket force him
to step away now you can contest it
there's no contest
what a shot that was fun what a start to
the summer league and and oh yeah the
big man's about to make his debut coming
up